well two las vegas pastors are charged
with ripping off taxpayers it's a case
the eight news now i-team has been
tracking for four years in a
never-before-seen interview the pastors
share their side of the story only to
the i-team the i-team's vanessa murphy
has the story
they were las vegas pastors in 2018. now
in 2022 joe and regina bryce are accused
of stealing from the health care system
we didn't do what we were accused of
doing at all the prices agreed to an on
camera interview with the 8 news now
i-team in 2020 while they were being
investigated for fraud but before they
were charged how concerned are you joe
and regina that
the case against you could move forward
and you could end up going to prison
it's not going to happen we're not
concerned at all
we serve a we serve a righteous god
regina has been indicted for health care
fraud while she and her husband joe also
face charges that they profited from the
alleged scheme according to this
indictment regina set up above and
beyond behavioral health services in
2016 and submitted fake claims to nevada
medicaid totaling 1.1 million dollars
according to this indictment against her
husband joe owned chance's behavioral
health and starting in 2017 fraudulent
claims were also submitted to medicaid
prosecutors point to four wire transfers
from the business account totaling more
than 392 thousand dollars
were patients definitely being seen at
both of those
yes yes every day yes yes
so then all the services were rendered
so then what do you think was the red
flag for the investigators
i i can't tell you we have no idea
we still don't to this day prosecutors
say services on this list build for
crisis intervention psychotherapy and
alcohol and drug screening never
happened and that the brices used the
tax dollars they received from medicaid
to live large they had multiple
properties they ran a restaurant a
couple of doors down they held services
at their narrow path ministries by the
time of this interview though homes and
businesses were raided by the irs and
other agencies their place of worship
and businesses were closed and they
filed for bankruptcy you have an eight
hundred thousand dollar house in las
vegas
five hundred thousand dollar house in
henderson
255 000 house in north las vegas was
that money earned
after the businesses were set up in las
vegas
yes
regina admitted even with no formal
health care background it was easy to
set up the health care businesses she
told us for less than 500 dollars she
obtained a health care provider id which
is needed to bill for medicaid but
according to documents obtained by the
eight news now i team joe and regina had
criminal histories which they did not
disclose on their applications that's
illegal for regina the letter refers to
convictions for a child abuse or neglect
charge assault or battery and an offense
involving a deadly weapon for joe the
letter refers to a drug conviction and a
weapons charge we're not crooks i've
never i've never been in trouble to
steal it i've never even stole a penny
candy in my life i don't have a criminal
record of stealing i'm not a thief i'm a
woman of god
since the indictments against the brices
the i-team requested a new interview
with them but the law firm representing
them declined our request the brices
pleaded not guilty they are not
currently in custody and defense
attorneys and prosecutors have until
october to file certain documents in
federal court we should also add the
i-team has learned there is a third
unnamed defendant but the case is sealed
vanessa murphy live local now